those Lego Batman movie is directed by
Chris McKay and stars Will Arnett as
Batman don't worry I'm not going to do
the whole video like that I just wanted
to open my video like that because I
thought it would be funny but after
doing it I can tell it probably wasn't
the lego movie still to this day is one
of the most surprising movies I've ever
seen I saw that movie and I had no
expectations for it I thought it was a
giant product placement movie I thought
it was going to be terrible and it was
hilarious so some of the funniest
animated films of that year and it has
now started a franchise and of course
one of the most popular characters in
history of anything is Batman
so Lego has a Batman so you know that's
going to happen and it did the Lego
Batman movie sees our favorite caped
crusader dealing with the fact that he
doesn't have a family
he's pretty depressed about that but he
has a hard time admitting it even though
everyone around him is constantly trying
to let him know that hey it's okay I'm
your buddy he's like no I'm Batman I
work alone leave me be I'm gonna sing
rap and do karate I'm awesome that's
right Batman wraps in this movie so I
mean there's definitely something to
look forward to that's for sure I went
into this movie really excited because
it's a combination of two things that I
love my favorite superhero of all time
and Legos these are both things I grew
up with and I am so happy to say I had a
great time with this movie this movie
was a complete blast from start to
finish the animation is really
spectacular but these are things that
have become expected nowadays you expect
movies like this to look technically
fantastic but the color scheme they used
to make this movie look really gorgeous
a lot of bright oranges and dark colors
to create the Lego gotham city but these
are things i expected going in what i'm
really happy they maintained was a
fantastic sense of humor the first lego
movie was very funny and this movie has
so many jokes that feels so packed in
there where almost every second is a
joke that is a bit of an issue that I
have with this movie and it's the same
basic issue I had with the first lego
movie this movie is really funny but
sometimes the humor is so fast and so
furious that it just keeps coming at you
and coming at you and coming at you that
it can be a little hard to keep up it
gets a little frenetic and since there
are so many jokes sometimes it's
actually hard to focus
one because you're still laughing from
another and then another one is made and
then there are times where you feel like
you've had a laugh exhaustion where
you've giggled and chuckled so many
times that you're just like okay I get
it they're making more funnies now okay
that was funny oh that was funny too
okay there's a lot of jokes whoo that's
it was funny so my biggest negative with
this movie is that there are so many
jokes that you can't always focus on
them that's a very minut negative this
was a total blast I really genuinely had
a great time with this film will arnett
was hilarious as the voice of Batman
this movie understands how to poke fun
at Batman's history all the way back to
the 60s and even before that there's a
brief brief joke at the old 1940s Batman
black and white cereal and not food
cereals but you know cereal like that
and a lot of jokes about the previous
Batman movies which a lot of them really
hit home for me because as I said I've
been a fan of this guy since I was a
little boy so it was really cool to see
a movie that understood what to make fun
of when it comes to Batman and what to
really exploit when it comes to this
character which leads me into something
I do want to say if you're the type of
person that doesn't like pop-culture
references in movies or you're annoyed
when movies acknowledge that other
movies exist like if that's really a
thing for you a pet peeve then this film
is going to annoy you because there's a
lot of them but if you're the kind of
person that understands that that type
of humor is exactly what they're going
for that type of very sarcastic ironic
humor then you're going to be right at
home
what they did was a Joker in this movie
I thought was brilliant
they have him in a not romantic
relationship with Batman where he really
just wants Batman to admit that Batman
loves to fight him that Batman truly
hates the Joker that he needs the Joker
to feel complete and Batman can't do
that and so the Joker feels betrayed and
it's just the way they go that route was
hilarious I loved it it does follow a
similar string of events that the
original lego movie did there's a big
song that movie had everything is
awesome this one has Batman rapping
about how incredible he is
I'll take Batman rapping
how incredibly is because just on
concept alone that's genius
but it does follow a similar string of
events that the lego movie did it tries
to harness that exact tone so if you're
okay with the fact that this is another
family movie with a lot of big sarcastic
humor and a lot of fun action sequences
and a whole bunch of different
characters that Lego can use at its
disposal and there's a lot as I said the
jokes can get a little bit too frenetic
at times there was one moment where
during a scene Batman asked if the
Suicide Squad was going to help him and
Barbara Gordon was like no and I was
like okay they referenced it and then
like literally 1 minute later Batman
makes a joke about how getting a team of
criminals together to fight other
criminals is stupid and I'm like you
just reference the Suicide Squad
positively and now you're making fun of
them so sometimes the jokes are so fast
that it's almost like they didn't even
realize they don't always make sense
together
that's really my only issue with the
film if they just kind of harness the
jokes and made the tone a little more
consistent between the serious family
stuff they have in this film and all of
that frenetic humor then I think that
would have improved a film but overall
as I said I really enjoyed this movie
and I can't wait to pick it up on
blu-ray and watch it again I'm gonna
give the Lego Batman movie of B+ guys
thank you very much for watching I do
have some cool news for you I got a
super early screening for Logan I just
found out yesterday unfortunately I was
planning on the entire month of February
being x-men reviews of movies that I
haven't reviewed I've already filmed all
four of the videos I'm going to do x-men
1 2 3 and an origins review with the
philippic they were going to go up once
a week leading up to the March 3rd
premiere of Logan unfortunately I guess
not really unfortunately I got a super
early screen for Logan and that's going
to be in the middle of February so
you're going to get a big influx of
x-men reviews here pretty soon starting
this Sunday with the first x-men leading
all the way up to origins because those
are the x-men films I haven't reviewed
on this channel guys you're the best
look forward to that thank you very much
for watching I do appreciate it very
much thank you once again and if you
like this you can click right here and
get
mine eyes
[Applause]
[Music]